so let's talk about how to make truly
scalable pages now HTML by default is
supposed to reflow text anyway and text
sizes are supposed to be consistent but
the worst side effect of this viewport
stuff by default is that even with
nothing set the mobile browser is going
to reflow text and render as if the
window were 980 pixels wide and then
scale it to fit it onto the screen this
may mean that the text looks really
small on my mobile browser by default so
the second way to use viewport is if
your page knows how to adapt to width
for example if it knows how to wrap the
contents based on screen width you can
simply set the width to device width
which tells the browser my website knows
how to adapt to your width this is
really the best approach to build
applications that scale their own layout
and make intelligent decisions about how
to do so rather than just trying to
scale a fixed layout to fit the screen